we have two different statements written
in english that i would like you to
pause this video and try to write as an
algebraic expression
all right now let's work on this first
one so you might be tempted to say all
right i have five so let me just write a
five
times and i'll write a dot because when
we're dealing with algebra if you write
a traditional multiplication sign it can
get confused with an x so five times the
difference of x and two the difference
of x and two we could write as
x
minus
but this expression has a problem
because whoever's interpreting it if
they're following order of operations
which they should that would mean that
they would multiply the 5 and the x
first and then subtract 2. but that's
not what's going on in the sentence it's
5 times
not x but the difference of x and 2. so
what you need to do is put parentheses
here to make sure that you take the
difference of x and 2 first and then
multiply that by 5.
now with that in mind let's tackle this
example right over here 10 times the sum
of y and 3.
well once again if you just wrote 10
times
the sum of y and 3 you'll run into the
same problem someone would interpret
this as hey maybe i should multiply 10
and y first because that's what order of
operations would tell me to do but
that's not what we want we want 10 times
not just y but the sum of y and 3. so
that's where the parentheses are really
important to make sure that we take the
sum of y and 3 first and then multiply
that by 10.